Chris Farley yes those guys were like
real best friends I was another kind of
best friend he had he when he get pissed
at at David he had a crazy temper Farley
so he would just be stewing mad about
nothing if a girl talk to him he'd be
like why is that girl what like he get
so angry that David was talking to a
girl or something he'd be like I'm going
to kill him let me
have come on you can do better than that
that feel a Dr and I'd say don't how
don't hit him and he'd be like no I got
I got to hit him ay I'm going to crush
him and I would say it doesn't make any
sense if you knock him out you're known
as a jerk and if you lose you're known
as just a giant
[__] and he'd be like you're right
you're right